we have an update on a story we first
brought you back in march
it's about a young woman who disappeared
in london on her way home from a night
out
sarah everhart's murder prompted a
nationwide debate over violence
harassment
and abuse of women roxanna siberia is
near the crime scene with new
developments on this story
roxanna good morning to you
good morning gail everard was walking
home through a populated area near here
after leaving a friend's house one
evening
she had just finished speaking to her
boyfriend on the phone to make plans for
the next day
when she vanished her body was found a
week later
50 miles outside london now police
officer wayne cousins has pleaded guilty
to kidnapping and raping her
in court yesterday he also accepted
responsibility for her death
everard's killing ignited widespread
grief and the seemingly everyday nature
of her actions on the night of her
disappearance
sparked outrage about women's safety in
britain with many women speaking out
about their own experiences of being
harassed
and assaulted that outcry was clear at
one vigil here
that had been banned because of coveted
restrictions clashes
erupted when police tried to break up
the gathering and arrested several women
the police response sparked protests and
condemnation
in the days that followed one newspaper
here is quoting london's chief of police
as saying
london is one of the safest largest
cities in the world and that female
officers are now patrolling this area
with help from the public
still many women from all walks of life
say more needs to be done
tony roxanna said berry for us in london
roxanna thank you very much